the thing is that it was an open
relationship though what does that mean
that she we were just clearly i mean
it's happened a few times you clearly
say that you're seeing other people and
then you have your momentum she sounds
like a confident woman right there
confident and secure well i i do the
same thing and when i tell them it's
like all right we're we're just having
fun and we communicate and we hang out
as friends and we have thrills
and the sex is great and then she moves
her way and i move my mind i still cared
about her more than yeah
what obligations do you have in this
relationship are you taking her on dates
are you paying for anything yeah yeah
what are you doing exactly i i go on
trips with her sometimes and you're
you're funding these trips yeah
so she you're not expecting her to do
anything and i don't mind at all so this
is part of the relationship it's like
look open
i'm gonna take care of you she she uh
she treats me in in a very interesting
way and there's more than one i mean i
think dating now is just so open and
we're slowly going through this phase of
realizing that we have so much freedom
in dating that we have to get rid of our
egos in the process of and embrace what
we're heading into everyone is talking
to a lot of people everyone has options
now the trick is
when you find someone worth settling
down with are you in the right position
to do it
did you clear out any past trauma are
you good at communicating do you have
things going on for you does the person
reciprocate that and then if you find it
you got to double down and make that
happen because right now it's just like
variable on variable when it comes on
dating whatever comes your way if you
like it if you don't well i see a lot of
nodding going on what did you agree with
right there that's how i listen
i didn't agree with the single thing
so nothing he said you agreed with but
you're like yeah i'm crazy as [ __ ] i'm
just gonna nod it here in your face i'm
honestly that was a crazy move yeah like
i thought you were totally agreeing
i think open relationships are [ __ ]
ridiculous i could never do it but i'm
nodding saying that's great that you can
do that so you nodding did you ever hook
up with someone more than once and it
wasn't a relationship um yeah then i i
was like i'm not gonna see them again i
don't know i just i feel like women are
a little bit more
um i feel like i need to
emotionally be into someone to continue
to see them otherwise i
i don't feel sexually attracted to them
well that is a difference between men
and women that's been very vocalized
especially on my boys fresh and fit or
like rollo tomasi they come on
women need to be emotionally invested
guys are just like
hot chick let's go and then have zero
emotional investment won't even maybe
call you again yeah right where as a
woman that's a lot harder to do i agree
i don't i can't remember the last time
yeah
you do agree amber you don't
what do you want to say
um just here i wanted her to finish
because you were like i never
so sorry to hear that um that's a
problem sounds like a guy told me
something interesting that what he was
said with with girls um when you have
sex with somebody in their minds the
relationship against and a lot of times
with guys when you have sex with someone
the relationship ends it's that like we
are getting ready the second we have sex
with somebody we're like emotionally
available and ready to continue and
they're like
and we're out and gotcha
um but in terms of i've actually been in
an open relationship for a really
healthy one for a year not now
prior um
and it worked really well because we
were both very honest and communicative
and i felt supported and loved by him
and also
um not jealous because i was also having
my own experiences and i they're of
course moments where you're like that
feels not great but then you also
remember all the things you mean like
emotionally like it hurt your heart yeah
like there are moments when you're like
okay i know he's on a date with somebody
else but that's okay he's saying
act normal but you really are not no no
i'm not not it's just obviously we're
human but i also loved him so much that
i wanted him to have those experiences
because when he would come back he'd
come back more confident this guy right
here
this term gets very overplayed but was
he a pretty high value man like he had
his [ __ ] together he had money he had
other options he wasn't just some
schmuck that you're like
was he pretty high value guy i just
never look at people like that but i
never have until i got to miami when i
had to start categorizing i'm not it's
not even a cat you know
you know if somebody has their [ __ ]
together has money has things going on
is successful are they young and up and
coming are they you know they they if
they play their cards right and they
work harder they can get there but
they're not there yet they're younger or
whatever i've always said and there's
guys who are just kind of like
yeah they're doing all right and
she said he was an artist so there's
your answer automatically
he was established he had money he could
be with
people he wanted to he had options yeah
he had options so you were comfortable
with him exploring those options yeah
because i know there's not another
amberjoy lane out there that's true i
know that it's maybe the truth and if
you wanted a different person then he
should go be with them go get him
[Music]